This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We built the cities for us. The concrete, the metal, and the glass were formed into countless austere structures designed to give comfort to squishy, hairless bipeds. When we made the cities, we were largely unconcerned with the feathered, the spineless, or the photosynthetic, but to quote our greatest scientist, Dr. Ian Malcolm, of Jurassic Park. Life finds a way, but the life that found a way to thrive within our city limits isn't celebrated for its ingenuity or lauded for its fortitude, the plants and animals that
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们为自己建造了城市。混凝土、金属和玻璃被塑造成无数严谨的结构，旨在为柔软、无毛的双足动物提供舒适。当我们建造城市时，我们很大程度上并不关心那些长羽毛的、无脊椎的或进行光合作用的生物，但引用我们最伟大的科学家，《侏罗纪公园》里的伊恩·马尔科姆博士的话来说：生命会找到出路。但那些在我们的城市范围内找到出路并茁壮成长的生命，并没有因为它们的独创性而受到赞美，也没有因为它们的坚韧而受到称赞，那些动植物……
have made it, the life that found away, is reviled. Familiarity has bred contempt at worst or in difference at best. We kick pigeons, we poison snails, we mow down even the most useful weeds. But in the Thenial Johnson's new book Unseen City, he implores us to slow down and notice the beauty and resilience of the life that thrives within our urban landscape. He encovers weeds that are tastier than you've imagined, squirrels are smarter than you suspected, and pigeons that exemplify their aristocratic origins.
那些成功生存下来的生命，那些找到了出路的生命，却遭到了唾弃。熟悉感最坏的结果是滋生轻蔑，最好的结果也是漠不关心。我们踢鸽子，毒杀蜗牛，甚至割除最有用的杂草。但在纳撒尼尔·约翰逊的新书《看不见的城市》中，他恳求我们放慢脚步，去注意那些在我们城市景观中茁壮成长的生命的魅力与韧性。他揭示了比你想象中更美味的杂草、比你怀疑中更聪明的松鼠，以及展现了它们贵族血统的鸽子。
He writes about all the gross stuff they do, too. There are no grosser than us humans, but let's just say that every time you admire the green, iridescent shimmer of the neck feathers on a pigeon, you will also be reminded of a thing called pigeon milk, and it will haunt your nightmares. A few weeks ago I interviewed Nathaniel Johnson in front of an audience at Nightlife, the adults only nighttime weekly event at the California Academy of Sciences. I had such a good time there and I enjoyed Unseen City so much that we thought we'd share it as a special episode.
他也写到了它们所做的所有恶心的事情。没有比我们人类更恶心的了，但我们只能说，每当你欣赏鸽子颈部羽毛那种绿色、彩虹般的光泽时，你也会想起一种叫“鸽乳”的东西，它会萦绕在你的噩梦中。几周前，我在加州科学院的成人夜间周常活动“夜生活”上采访了纳撒尼尔·约翰逊。我在那里玩得很开心，而且我非常喜欢《看不见的城市》，所以我们想把它作为一期特别节目分享给大家。
I started out by asking Nathaniel what a synanthrope was and why he decided to write a whole book about them. Synanthropes are the creatures that thrive together with humans. So sin is together in the Greek and Amphro is human, sin and throbes. And these are the all the creatures that are living right alongside us, the weeds springing up through the cracks, the starlings that are growing generation after generation, you're attic. starlings that are growing generation after generation, you're addict. And I've always been kind of a wannabe naturalist who's interested in these types of things.
我首先问纳撒尼尔什么是“共生生物”，以及为什么他决定为它们写一整本书。“共生生物”是那些与人类共同繁荣的生物。在希腊语中，“syn”是“一起”，“anthro”是“人类”，即“synanthrope”。这些就是所有生活在我们身边的生物，从裂缝中长出的杂草，一代又一代在你的阁楼里繁衍的椋鸟。我一直是个想成为博物学家的人，对这类事情很感兴趣。
But for some reason, these particular creatures always seemed like they weren't worthy of real study. And so I kind of ignored them until I had a baby girl. And she didn't ignore them. She was incredibly interested in these creatures. So I started looking at them too. And when I started looking at them in the way that she did through these fresh eyes, I started seeing things that I'd never seen before.
但出于某种原因，这些特定的生物似乎总是不值得进行真正的研究。所以我一直忽略它们，直到我有了女儿。她并没有忽略它们。她对这些生物非常感兴趣。所以我开始关注它们。当我开始像她那样用这种全新的眼光去观察它们时，我开始看到我以前从未见过的东西。
And that was really cool because you can go out into the woods and find something new that you've never seen before. And it's like, that's amazing, but it's even more magical when it's been there right in front of you, day after day, right underneath your nose, and then you are able to look at it in a new way and see something that just pops out and is amazing. Do you remember the first thing that she pointed out that you felt like you had to find an answer for her? Yeah, there was this thing that would happen pretty much every day as we were going to She pointed out that you felt like you had to find an answer for her?
这真的很酷，因为你可以走进树林，发现一些你从未见过的新东西。这很棒，但当它日复一日地就在你面前，就在你的眼皮底下，而你能够以一种新的方式去观察它，并看到一些突然显现出来且令人惊叹的东西时，那就更神奇了。你还记得她指出的第一件让你觉得必须为她找到答案的事情吗？是的，几乎每天我们去……她指出的第一件让你觉得必须为她找到答案的事情吗？
Yeah, there was this thing that would happen pretty much every day as we were going to her daycare. I'd have her in the front pack, and she would point at basically everything that we passed. And so she'd be like, what's that? And I'd say that's a tree. And she'd say that. That's still actually the same tree even.
是的，几乎每天我们去她日托中心时都会发生一件事。我把她背在前面的背带里，她会指着我们经过的几乎所有东西。她会问：“那是什么？”我会说：“那是一棵树。”然后她会说：“那个。”其实那还是同一棵树。
It's that. And so I had this terrible choice between saying tree, tree, tree over and over again, or listening to our screen for the entire time. And so I decided to complicate the game a little bit by making a new rule, which was that I could only say the same thing one time. So I could say tree, but then I would have to say branch, you know, twig, leaf, stamen, and by doing that, this one time I saw these tiny little flowers
“那个。”所以我面临一个糟糕的选择：要么一遍又一遍地说“树、树、树”，要么全程听她尖叫。所以我决定通过制定一个新规则来让游戏复杂一点，那就是同一个词我只能说一次。所以我可以说“树”，但接下来我就必须说“树枝”、“嫩枝”、“叶子”、“雄蕊”。通过这样做，有一次我看到了这些微小的花朵……
on this tree that I'd never seen before, and we just got close to it, and there were these beautiful little yellow flowers. And so then I had to go find what the tree was. And it was just this wonderful moment. And then, you know, we came back later and saw the same flowers. And we saw they were developing into seed pods. And she remembered and she was like, whoa, that's cool. And so that was the first real moment. Right? It's like, there's stuff out here that I could be noticing that I'm not.
在这棵树上，我以前从未见过，我们走近一看，是那些美丽的小黄花。所以我不得不去查那是什么树。那真是一个美妙的时刻。后来，你知道，我们回来时又看到了同样的花。我们看到它们正在长成豆荚。她记住了，她说：“哇，真酷。”所以那是第一个真正的时刻。对吧？就像是，这里有些东西我本可以注意到，但我却没有。
Right. And you keep a toolkit for noticing things, and one of my favorites. So on my show, 99% invisible, we have a saying, it's always read the black. And it's not because all plaques are fantastic. Many of them are really boring and factually incorrect. But at least if you're the type of person that reads the plaque,
没错。你保留了一个用于观察事物的工具包，其中一个我最喜欢。在我的节目《99%隐形》中，我们有一句口头禅：“总是阅读牌匾”。这并不是因为所有的牌匾都很棒。很多牌匾真的很无聊，而且事实错误。但至少如果你是那种会阅读牌匾的人，
your person who notices the story in places. And you have this corollary that I love that's sort of the equivalent in the natural wonders of the city'scape always eat the weed. And so how does that sort of worked into how you cultivate awareness in the natural world? So if you always eat the weed, you walk through the world in a very different way. And I should say that we're talking about edible weed, Sarah, though. Don't eat every weed, but there's a surprising number of them that are edible.
你就是一个会在各个地方注意到故事的人。你有一个我非常喜欢的推论，在城市的自然奇观中相当于“总是吃掉杂草”。那么，这如何融入到你培养对自然世界意识的方式中呢？所以，如果你总是吃掉杂草，你走在世界上的方式就会非常不同。我应该说明我们说的是可食用的杂草，莎拉。不要吃掉所有的杂草，但其中有惊人数量的杂草是可以食用的。
And all these things that grow in these gritty situations, a lot of them happen to be pretty tasty if you catch them in the right situation. We just interact with nature generally through our eyes. We look at stuff. Sometimes maybe we'd like listen to bird song or smell the roses or the skunk or whatever, but we rarely interact with nature
所有这些在艰苦环境中生长的东西，如果你在合适的情况下遇到它们，很多其实相当美味。我们通常只是通过眼睛与自然互动。我们看东西。有时也许我们会听听鸟鸣，或者闻闻玫瑰或臭鼬什么的，但我们很少通过把自然放进嘴里来与它互动。当你这样做时，所有的感官都会聚焦，因为你有口腔里的触感。气味会从鼻后部升起。有咀嚼感，当然还有味道。而且你开始以不同的方式看待事物，因为一旦大脑意识到那是食物，这堆你以前无法真正区分的杂草，
by putting it in our mouths. And when you do that, all of the senses snap into focus because you've got the feel in the mouth. The scent goes up the back of your nose. There's a crunch and the taste, of course. And you also start seeing things differently because as soon as the brain registers, that that's food, this mishmash of weeds that you couldn't really distinguish before,
就会立刻变得清晰起来。我不擅长记住不同的物种名称，但如果是某种我可以吃的东西，出于某种进化原因，就像是：“哦，那个。”我记得旱金莲，还有那些刚长出来的蒲公英，锦葵之类的东西。哇。那么我们来谈谈鸽子吧。我有点觉得它们是恶心的、
comes right into focus. And I'm terrible at remembering different species names, but if it's something that I can eat, for some reason there's this like evolutionary thing that It's like, oh, that. I remember the nasturtions and the, you know, the dandelions when they're just coming in and the malo and that sort of thing. Wow. So let's talk about pigeons. I kind of view them as disgusting,
长满虱子的蜥蜴。显然你并不这么看。到这一章结束时，我也不再那么想了。那么我们为什么讨厌它们？因为普遍来说，人们真的不喜欢它们。关于鸽子，我们有什么误解？我认为鸽子发生的事情是，我的意思是，它们确实令人反感。
lice, ridden, lizards. You don't view them that way, obviously. And by the end of the chapter, I didn't feel that way. So why do we hate them? Because universally, people don't really like them. And what are we getting wrong about pigeons? I think that what happened with pigeons is that, I mean, they are legitimately revolting.
让我们把这一点摆在桌面上。记下了。但我们觉得它们真正令人厌恶的所有事情，其实都是由我们人类造成的，因为我们培育它们以获得巨大的产量。然后我们把它们放在这种环境中，喂给它们各种各样的食物。
Let's just put that on the table. Noted. But all the things that we find really loathsome about them are really caused by us, by humans, because we bred them to be massively productive. And then we put them in this situation where we fed them all kinds of food.
我们制造了海量的食物垃圾供它们食用。它们疯狂地繁殖。所以它们数量过剩了。它们被挤在一起。它们疯狂地繁殖。所以它们数量过剩了，它们被挤在一起，感染了寄生虫和疾病。我们觉得它们恶心的很多事情都是这个结果。那些是别的事情。那些是别的事情。
And we created this massive amount of food ways that they could eat. And they reproduced like crazy. And so then they're overpopulated. And they're all squished together. And they could eat and they reproduced like crazy. And so then they're overpopulated and they're all squished together and they get parasites and diseases. And a lot of the things that we find disgusting about them are a result of that. Those are other things. Those are other things.
但它们一开始并不是那样的。这些鸽子有着高贵的起源。没错。所以鸽子确实是贵族的鸟类。它们最初可能是在中东被驯化的，然后随着罗马人和罗马的上层阶级传播到欧洲。它们被融入了罗马房屋的建筑中。托斯卡纳别墅的经典元素之一就是这种“眺望台”，一种你可以走出去的塔状结构，
But they didn't start like that. These had noble origins, these pigeons. Right. So pigeons are really a bird of the aristocracy. They were first domesticated probably in the Middle East, and then they spread around Europe with the Romans and with Roman upper class, really. They were built into the architecture of Roman houses. One of the classic elements of the Tuscan Villa is this Belvedere, this top-like structure that you can go out
欣赏美丽的景色，那就是鸽舍。你知道，建筑顶部这种露天的结构，现在它成了美丽、庄严的上层阶级房屋的常见特征。然后它们也随着上流社会来到了美国。魁北克的第一任总督塞缪尔·德·尚普兰是将它们带到新大陆的人。它们在美国传播开来，因为总督和政要们会把它们送给彼此。你必须在你的房子里或附近有一个鸽舍。所以它们随着上流社会传播开来。但后来它们变得非常成功。随着美国变得越来越成功，我们开始生产越来越多的食物，并开始建造这些中间有雕像的广场。鸽子开始占据这些地方并接管了它们。如果你是一种极其普通的东西，你就无法真正保持你作为贵族象征的地位。
and see the beautiful view, and that was a pigeon house. You know, this open roofed structure at the top of the building, and now it's this common feature of a beautiful, stately upper-class house. And then they came to the US with the upper-crust as well. Samuel Champlain, the first governor of Quebec, was the person to bring them to the new world. And they spread across the US because governors and dignitaries
所以它们失宠了。你也可以在语言中看到这一点。关于鸽子，有趣的事情之一是“pigeon”和“dove”这两个词。很长一段时间里，它们只是混在一起。这两者之间没有科学上的区别。它们都属于同一个科，通常某种东西的通用名称既可以是“pigeon”也可以是“dove”。但在某个时候，所有好的东西都是“dove”，
would give them to each other. And you had to have a pigeon roost in your house or nearby. And so they spread with upper-crust. But then they became really successful. And as America became more and more successful, and we started producing more and more food, and started building these plazas with statues in the middle of them. Pigeons started taking to those places and taking them over. And you can't really maintain your status as a symbol of the aristocracy if you're an incredibly common thing.
所有坏的东西都是“pigeon”。你今天还能看到这一点。我的意思是，如果你试着改变一下，人们对鸽子有一种巨大的文化反感，对吧？所以如果你想到像“鸽子肥皂”或“鸽子巧克力棒”，它就是行不通，或者你可以使用，你会想到它在圣经中的用法，比如圣灵以鸽子的形式从天而降。所以它们经历了一场彻底的转变，我有点同情它们。
And so they fell from grace. And you can see this happening in the language, too. One of the interesting things about pigeons is the words pigeon and dove. For a long time, they were just mixed together. There's no scientific distinction between those two things. It's all kind of the same family, often the common name of something will both be a pigeon and a dove. But at some point, everything good was a dove,
如果你仔细观察它们，它们是美丽的鸟类，如果它们没有生病和破烂的话。我们一直处于与鸽子的冷战，甚至可能是热战中。而且这并不怎么奏效。那么我们处理鸽子的方式有哪些？没错。所以鸽子控制行业是一个相当庞大的行业。你可以做很多事情。你可以安装尖刺来阻止鸽子。
and everything bad was a pigeon. And you can see it today. I mean, if you try and change it around, there's this huge cultural antipathy toward pigeons, right? So if you think of like pigeon soap or pigeon chocolate bars, it just doesn't work or you could use, you would think about it in like the uses in the Bible, like the Holy Spirit descending from heaven in the form of a pigeon. And so they've undergone this radical transformation, and I sort of feel for them.
你可以安装阻挡它们的网。它们甚至有像微型电围栏那样的东西来让鸽子远离。但都没用。我的意思是，它们在一定程度上是有效的，你可以把鸽子从一栋建筑上赶走，但它们可以去下一栋建筑。这就是它们所做的。只要有食物来源，鸽子就会在那里。没错。好吧，让我们谈谈鸽乳。好的。拜托，我读到这个时，真的感到非常不安。所以我希望你让这个房间里的所有人都感到不安。什么是鸽乳？所以通常我们认为哺乳动物才会分泌乳汁。
If you look at them closely, there are these beautiful birds, if they're not diseased and wrapped. We're kind of in this cold war, maybe even a hot war with pigeons all the time. And it doesn't really work all that well. So what are the ways that we deal with pigeons? Right. So the pigeon control industry is a pretty massive industry. And you can do a lot of things. You can put spikes out to stop the pigeons.
是的。完全正确。但它是一种非常有用的营养输送装置，鸟类也发现了这一点，或者至少鸽子发现了这一点。这完全是趋同进化。这并不是某种在进化树上传播的东西。它的结构非常相似，但完全是独立衍生的。本质上发生的是，鸟类通过喉咙内部分泌一些营养物质，鸟类喉咙内部有一个小囊，
You can put netting that blocks them. They even have like miniature electric fences to keep pigeons away. And none of it works. I mean, it all works to a certain degree in that you can push pigeons off of one building, but they can just go to the next building. And that's what they do. And as long as the food source is there, the pigeons will be there. Right. Okay, so let's get on to the pigeon milk. Okay. Please, I read this, and it was really upsetting to me. So I want you to upset all these people here in this room. What is pigeon milk? So normally we think of mammals giving milk.
叫做“嗉囊”。它收集在嗉囊里，这是一种黄色的、奶酪状的……一点也不恶心，你说得对。然后乳鸽，小鸟把头伸进父母的喉咙里，用力挤压以获得鸽乳。雄性和雌性都会产生这种东西。这是自然界的一个美丽的奇迹。当你研究鸽子时，
Yes. It's exactly right. But it's a really useful delivery device of nutrients, and birds have figured it out too, or at least pigeons have figured it out too. And it's completely convergent evolution. It's not like this is something that has spread up the evolutionary tree. It's very similar in its structure, but it's completely independently derived. And essentially what happens is the birds secrete some nutrients through the inside of their throats, and there's a little pouch that birds have inside their throats
你注意到它们中有很多腿部残疾，为什么这么多鸽子腿部残疾是一个谜。是的，我不知道你是否见过这个，但我一仔细观察鸽子就开始看到这一点，它们经常会少一个脚趾，或者完全失去脚，只剩下一个残肢。而且比例非常大。
called the crop. And it collects in the crop and it's this sort of yellowish, cheesy, not gross at all, you're right. And then the squabs, the little birds stick their heads down the parents' throats and thrust to get the pigeon milk out. Both the males and the females produce this. It's a beautiful wonder of nature. When you were researching pigeons,
每次我观察时，我都会看到，你知道，那里可能有10只鸽子，其中一两只的脚会有问题。当我开始寻找这个问题的答案时，我发现了所有这些想法。人们非常确定有像猫这样的捕食者在攻击它们的脚。但为什么它们只攻击脚呢？或者它们感染了葡萄球菌。我花了好长一段时间才弄明白这一点。这几乎贯穿了整个研究过程。
you noticed that a bunch of them have messed up legs, and there's a mystery to why so many pigeons have messed up legs. Yeah, so I don't know if you've seen this, but I started seeing this as soon as I started looking closely at pigeons that they often would be missing a toe or they'd be missing their foot entirely, and it was just the stump. And it was like this huge percentage.
我一直在追踪这些不同的线索。最终，我发现顶尖的鸽子研究员说：“哦，是的，所有这些都是胡说八道。”发生的情况是，它们缠上了细线或头发，这在城市里非常普遍，它缠绕在它们的脚上，它们没有任何办法弄掉它，它就缠得越来越紧，导致了这些病变。通常鸟类不会这样，因为大多数鸟类是跳跃的，而鸽子是蹒跚而行，所以它们在很多方面非常适应城市，除了这个可怕的怪诞缺陷。
Every time I would look, I would see, you know, there'd be like 10 pigeons out there, and one or two of them would have something wrong with their feet. And when I started looking for the answers about this, I found all of these ideas. And people were pretty sure that there were predators like cats were attacking their feet. But why would they just attack the feet? Or they were getting staff infections. And it took me a really long time to figure this out. It was sort of throughout the entire course of the research.
出于某种原因，它们的喙……它们没有能力解开。它们没有能力解开它。哇。好吧，那很悲伤。好吧，我现在对鸽子感到难过了。在书中，大多数动植物都是在混凝土景观中茁壮成长的物种，但人类并没有刻意让它们容易生存。银杏树的情况并非如此，如果不是因为人们在城市里种植它们，这种树可能已经不存在了。那么为什么银杏不适合自然界，
I was tracing down these different threads. And eventually, what I found, the premier pigeon researcher said, oh yes, all of this is nonsense. What happens is that they pick up little bits of thread or hair, which is incredibly common in cities, and it gets tangled around their feet, and they don't have any way to get it off, and it just gets tangled tighter and tighter, and it causes these lesions, and normally birds don't get this, because most birds hop, and pigeons kind of shuffle, and so they're really well adapted to cities in many ways, except for this one terrible grotesque flaw.
而它们在城市里却表现得这么好？银杏的黄金时代是白垩纪。正如我们所知，那是银杏统治世界的时代，我总是想到那个时代。它们只是和恐龙共享世界。它们不在乎。真的，它们是主宰。那时，银杏有一些进化伙伴。它们有某种生物会帮助它们分发种子。而今天，我们根本不知道那是什么。这是一个人们仍在试图弄清楚的谜。
Some reason they're beaks just, they're not capable of tinkling. They're not capable of untankling it. Wow. Well, that's sad. Okay, I feel bad for pigeons now. In the book, most of the flora and fauna are species that thrive in the concrete landscape, but humans didn't purposely make it easy for them to survive. That's not the case for the ginkgo by Loba, which is the tree that probably wouldn't exist anymore if it weren't for people planting them in cities. So why are Ginkgo's unsuitable for nature
这是一个双重谜团，因为它们的种子闻起来像微波炉烤死了一样。真是太糟糕了。有雄性和雌性银杏，雌性产生种子。如果你在九月到十一月期间在它们附近，你会注意到的。它停下来了。这是你可以睁开眼睛去发现的一件事。你可以停下来找到种子。并注意到它们闻起来有多糟糕。
and why do they do so well in cities? The golden age of Ginkgo's was the Cretaceous. When Ginkgo's ruled the world, as we all know, I'd always think of that era. They just shared it with dinosaurs. They didn't care. Really, they were in charge. At that time, Ginkgo's had some evolutionary partner. They had some kind of creature that would help them distribute their seeds. And today, we have no idea what this is. It's this mystery that people are still trying to figure out.
但一定有什么东西喜欢这种气味，一定吃过它并把它带到了不同的地方。在某个时候，种子分发者可能灭绝了。这仅仅意味着随着气候变化，银杏无法跑赢冰川。所以你在世界各地都能看到它们。它们有这些非常坚韧的皮革状叶子，所以它们是很好的化石，人们在
And it's a double mystery because their seeds smell like microwave to death. It's just terrible. There's male and female ginkos, and the females produce the seeds. And if you're around them around September, November, you'll notice. It's stopped. That's one thing you can open your eyes to. You can stop and find the seeds. And notice just how terrible they smell.
各地都能找到它们。然后它们退缩，退缩，再退缩，直到只剩下中国境内的几个山谷。它们的整个家族也被消灭了。它们是这种植物生命中整个门类中仅存的物种。然后人类出现了，人们爱上了银杏。
But there was something that must have liked this smell and must have eaten it and carried it to different places. And at some point, the seed distributor probably died out. And it simply meant that the ginkos couldn't outrun the glaciers as the climate changed. And so you see them all across the world. They have these really tough leathery leaves so they make great fossils and people find
事实证明，银杏也挺喜欢我们。它们可以在受污染的空气中茁壮成长，在混凝土中表现良好，在部分光照下表现良好，这对城市来说是完美的。它们以耐受虐待而闻名，你知道，被送货卡车撞到，或者靠近原子弹。在广岛原子弹爆炸地点仅一公里处就有一棵幸存并重新生长。这是一个令人惊叹的故事，它们在数百万年里勉强生存下来，然后它们发现自己处于地球历史上这个疯狂的时刻，它们可以在人类城市中茁壮成长。因为果实，种子太臭了，我们倾向于只种植
them all over the place. And then they retreat and they retreat and they retreat until they're just a couple valleys in China where they're left. And their entire family gets wiped out too. They're the only remaining species of this whole division of plant life that remains. And then people come along and people fall in love with ginkos.
雄性物种，对吧？没错。我们倾向于只种植雄性物种，对吧？没错。人们试图只种植雄性，有时他们会弄错。这很难，你知道，它们需要30年才能达到性成熟。所以有时候就像是：“哎呀，我想那是一棵雌性。”但即使是雄性也有它们的缺点，因为它们会产生大量的花粉。是的。所以无论如何。
And it turns out the ginkos kind of love us too. They can thrive in polluted air, they do well in concrete, they do well in partial light, which is perfect for cities. They're famously good at taking abuse, you know, being backed into by a delivery truck or or close to Adam Baum. There's one just a kilometer away from the Hiroshima bomb site that survived and re-grue. It's this kind of amazing story where they just barely hung on for millions and millions of years, and then they happen to find themselves in this crazy point in the Earth's history where they could thrive in human cities. Because the fruits, the seeds are so stinky, we tend to plant only the
所以你发现银杏种子在一定程度上是可食用的。一旦你去掉了周围那层非常臭的果肉。我这里有一段我不想从你的书中读出来的引语，但我真的很喜欢。它说：“银杏毒素在结构上类似于维生素B6，摄入过多会干扰我们合成这种维生素的能力。这可能会引发一种生化级联反应，
male of the species, right? That's right. We tend to plant only the male of the species, right? That's right. People try to just plant the males and sometimes they get it wrong. And it's hard, you know, it's like 30 years before they become sexually mature. So then it's like, oops, I guess that was a female. But even the males have their downsides because then, you know, they produce tons and tons of pollen. Yeah. So one way or the other.
特别是在儿童中，可能导致癫痫发作甚至死亡。”这听起来很令人担忧，但这并没有阻止我。什么会阻止你吃东西？总的来说，我们对有毒的自然界是否有点太偏执了？是的，我认为我们对有毒的自然界，以及总的来说对毒素，有点太偏执了。对于我做的上一本书，我最终研究了
So you discovered that kinko seeds were edible at a certain point. Once you get rid of that really stinky flesh that's around them. And I just have this quote that I don't want to read from your book, which I really liked a lot. It says, ginko toxin is similar in structure to vitamin B6 and eating too much of it interferes with our ability to synthesize the vitamin. That can provoke a biochemical cascade
很多关于我们与植物的关系。当你观察那种关系，那种动物与植物之间的协同进化交换时，那是一部化学战争史。植物产生越来越疯狂的化学物质来试图保护自己免受动物的伤害。你会认为它们会赢，对吧？因为它们有这些惊人的实验室，它们可以合成出让
that, especially in children, may lead to seizures and even death. This sounds alarming, but it wasn't enough to deter me. What does deter you from eating things? And in general, are we a little too paranoid about poisonous nature? Yeah, I think we're a little too paranoid about poisonous nature. And just poisons in general for the previous book that I did. I ended up researching a
NSA的人流口水的东西。你知道，疯狂的东西。但它们没有，因为动物真的很强悍。基本上动物会说：“嗯，不错的毒药，植物。我想我会少吃你一点。”所以我们进化出了处理这种问题的能力。你花足够的时间研究这段历史，你真的会领悟到“剂量决定毒性”的教训。
whole bunch about our relationship with plants. And when you look at that relationship, that co-evolutionary exchange between animals and plants. It's a history of chemical warfare. Plants produce crazier and crazier chemicals to try and protect themselves from animals. And you would think that they would just win, right? Because they have these amazing laboratories where they can just synthesize stuff that would make people
特别是对于银杏种子，是的，确实存在中毒的可能性，但也有数百万人在数千年来食用它的历史。所以我对此感觉还不错。那么它们尝起来怎么样？首先，我自己试了一下。我对毒素有点偏执，所以我煮了又煮，煮了又煮，我敲开了银杏果，
at the NSA just salivate. And you know, crazy stuff. But they don't because animals are really, really tough. And basically animals are like, hmm, pretty good poison there plant. Guess I'll eat a little bit less of you. And so we've evolved the ability to deal with this. And you really, you spend enough time with this history, you really take in the lesson that the dose makes the poison.
它就像一个干瘪的小棕色东西。我想：“不知道它是不是应该看起来那样。”它真的很硬，尝起来有点像焦糖。然后我去找了一个中国烹饪爱好者，她知道如何正确准备这个，她做了它。这有点让人失望，因为它太温和了。它只是，它有点粘，非常温和，略带苦味，但不是特别有味道，不是。它有点像煮过头的蘑菇，只是一点点，在中国烹饪中，它因其质地而不是味道而受到重视。
And with ginkgo seeds especially, yes, there is this possibility of poisoning, but also there is this history of millions of people eating this for thousands of years. So I felt pretty okay with it. So how did they end up tasting? So first of all, I tried to do it myself. And I was a little bit paranoid about the poison, and so I cooked it and cooked it and cooked it, and I cracked up in the ginkgo nut,
没错。还有它所谓的药用价值。是的，药用价值是怎么回事？我不知道。我的意思是，我们通常谈论的药用价值与银杏叶中的化合物有关，银杏已被证明有助于促进血液循环。
and it was like this shriveled little brown thing. I was like, I wonder if that's how it's supposed to look. It's like it's really hard and kind of caramel tasting. And then I went to someone who's Chinese cooking enthusiast and knows how to prepare this correctly, and she made it. And it was a little bit of a letdown because it was so mild. It's just this, it's kind of a tacky, very mild, slightly bitter, but not especially flavorful, not. It's kind of like overcook moky, it's just a little bit, and it's really valued more for its texture in Chinese cuisine than for its taste.
这可以帮助解决诸如促进大脑血液循环之类的问题。所以也许，是的，可能确实有某种方式让你变得更聪明，但这有点牵强。它确实通过稀释血液来促进血液循环。所以如果你已经在服用血液稀释剂等药物，它可能会有一些危险的并发症。所以。
Right. And it's supposed medical properties as well. Yeah, what's the deal with medical properties? I don't know. I mean, the medical properties that we generally talk about have to do with compounds in the leaves and ginkgo below, but has been shown to help facilitate blood flow.
在结束之前，我想再谈谈一个物种，但书里有很多，你一定要去看看。我想谈谈乌鸦。乌鸦是书中看起来最自觉地利用人类城市景观的物种。我的意思是，它们极其聪明。那些对我们人类可能不太好的东西，
And that can help with things like facilitate and blood flow in the brain. So maybe, yes, there might be some way in which it makes you smarter, but it's kind of a stretch. And it does facilitate the blood flow by kind of thinning the blood, too. So it can have some dangerous complications with, if you're already on blood thinners or such. So.
比如路灯，人们认为这会扰乱我们的昼夜节律。但乌鸦非常喜欢路灯。所以告诉我们一点关于这一点，以及它们是如何特别地融入我们的生活的。这是一个谜，因为乌鸦的数量激增。看起来乌鸦并没有激增，实际上只是乌鸦在城市中聚集。
I wanted to hit on one more species before we wrap it up, but there's a bunch of them in the book and you should definitely check it out. I want to talk about crows a little bit. Crows are the species in the book that seem to most knowingly take advantage of human cityscapes. I mean, they're shockingly bright. Things that are probably not good for us as humans,
所以问题是，为什么乌鸦会进入城市？一个解释是路灯。因为如果你是一只乌鸦，世界上最可怕的东西是大角鸮，因为它们在黑暗中飞来飞去，它们巨大，它们无声，它们会俯冲下来把你吃掉。如果你有路灯，你可以看到它们过来。所以这可能是乌鸦搬进城市的原因。
like streetlights, people think that upsets our circadian rhythms. Like crows are all about streetlights. So tell us a little bit about that and how they've particularly worked their way into our lives. There's this mystery because there's this boom in crows. And it doesn't seem like there's really a boom in crows, but actually just a concentration of crows in cities.
哇，我们在保护它们。我们在保护它们。它们一直开着可怕的灯。从根本上说，当我读到这里时，我觉得这其实都是关于故事。所以我们一直在做关于平凡和丑陋事物的报道。我可以被吸引，比如最丑的建筑。
And so then the question is, why are crows coming into cities? And one explanation for that is street lights. Because if you're a crow, the scariest thing in the world is a gray horned owl, because they just fly around in the dark, and they're huge, and they're silent, and they just swoop down and totally eat you. And if you have street lights, you can see them coming. And so that may be why pros are moving into cities.
如果它有一个好故事，我就会全身心投入。我们做了一个关于那些充气管状人的故事，你知道吗？那些蠢透了。但你有一个人谈论它们，他是来自特立尼达的，他说：“那家伙跳得像风暴一样。”这简直是史上最棒的事情。现在我爱死那些东西了。
Wow, we're protecting them. We're protecting them. They're awful lights on all the time. Fundamentally, when I was reading this, it was like, it's really all about story. So like we do stories about sort of mundane and ugly things all the time. And I can be seduced, like the ugliest building.
这才是重点。你找到了这些东西的故事，突然之间，这种自然，原本被设定为一种滋扰，或者在我们脑海中像是一种滋扰，变成了一个你可以爱上的东西。现在每次我经过那些管状人时，我都会想起那个故事。它让我的生活变得更丰富了一点，
If it has a good story, I'm like all about it. And we did a story about those inflatable tube men, you know? Those are dumb as hell. But you have this guy talking about him and he's from Trinidad and he goes, that dunce en up a storm like that. And it's like the greatest thing ever. And now I love those things.
因为我听到了那个人的声音，我想到了整个故事。我开始了解的所有这些生物也是如此。因为在上班路上，如果我早上在公交车站停下来，而不是在脑海里因为有乌鸦叫而感到烦恼，我会抬头看看它是否正在和松鼠争吵，
And that's really what this is about. You find the story of these things and all of a sudden, this nature, which is kind of set up to be a nuisance or like in our heads, like a nuisance, is a thing you can fall in love with. Every time I pass one of those two men now, I think of that story. And it makes my life a little bit richer
并想知道那是怎么回事。或者我会停下来仔细看看树上长出的花，心想：“哦，那告诉我关于那棵树的一些事情。”所有这些东西都在向我们讲述故事。我只是希望能读懂这些故事，并完全追溯叙事。这些生物在分发报纸，就像城市里地铁口的人那样。我真的很想能读懂那些报纸，
because I hear that guy's voice and I think of that whole story. And the same is true with all of these creatures that I've started to get to know. Because on my way to work, if I stop at the bus stop in the morning, instead of just being kind of annoyed in the back of my head that there's a crow calling, I'll look up and see if it's having a squabble
并在我走过这个世界时，对它有那种丰富的理解。所以如果这里的人，他们离开这里，他们想出去做你做过的事。你有什么任务给他们，让他们开始注意到一些事情吗？是的，有一件事，有很多事情你可以做，但有一件事就在你面前，我的意思是到处都是鸽子，我们谈了很多关于鸽子的话题。
with a squirrel and wonder what that's about. Or I'll stop up and see if it's having a squabble with a squirrel and wonder what that's about, or I'll stop to look closely at the flowers that are coming out in the tree and be like, oh, that's telling me something about that particular tree. All of these things are telling stories to us. And I just would like to be able to read those stories and fully follow the narrative back. These creatures are passing out newspapers, the way the guys do in the city at the top of the subway. And I'd like to really be able to read those newspapers
有人能告诉我鸽子的眼睛是什么颜色的吗？我听到了一个正确的答案，但为什么我们不留着它，仔细看看呢？下次你看到它们时，这真的很疯狂。所以当你这样做时，找到它，把它发到推特上，加上“Unseen City”标签，我们会关注它。所以如果你像我一样，在床上读书，在你的配偶旁边，你喜欢说：“嘿，你知道蜗牛吗？它们有两个触角，这样它们就能找到钙。”这就是为你准备的书，我的朋友们。每五分钟，你就会说出这样的话。纳撒尼尔，非常感谢你来到这里。《99%隐形》是山姆·格林斯潘、德莱尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯德、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、谢里夫·优素福和我，罗曼·马尔斯。感谢旧金山加州科学院的“夜生活”活动，它在金门公园。
and have that rich understanding of my world as I walk through it. So if people here, they leave here, they want to go out and do what you did. Do you have like a assignment for them to sort of like begin to notice something? Yeah, so one thing, there's a bunch of things that you could do, but one thing that's right in front of you, I mean there's pigeons everywhere, we've talked a lot about pigeons.
你可以在每周四晚上在博物馆与好奇的成年人一起探索音乐、生物和鸡尾酒。这是一个很酷的日子，你一定要去。我们是91.7 KLW旧金山的一个项目，由加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的建筑和室内设计公司ArcSign制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，你可以在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，但探索塑造我们世界设计的99%隐形活动的最好方式是成为我们网站的朋友，网址是99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Can anybody tell me what color a pigeon's eyes are? I heard a correct answer, but why don't we just leave it and take a close look? Next time you see them, it's really crazy. So like when you do it, find it, put it on Twitter, tag it with Unseen City, and we'll watch for it. So if you're like me and you read in bed, next to your spouse, and you like to go, hey, you know what about snails? They have two antenna so that they can find calcium. This is the book for you, my friends. Every five minutes, you're going to be saying something like that. Nathaniel, thank you so much for being here. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan Delaney Hall, Kurt Colesde, Katie Mingle, Avery, Truffleman, Sharif, Yousef, and me Roman Mars. Thanks to Nightlife at the California Academy of Sciences in San Francisco, it's Golden Gate
有人能告诉我鸽子的眼睛是什么颜色的吗？我听到了一个正确的答案，但我们为什么不先放一放，仔细观察一下呢？下次你见到它们时，真的会觉得很疯狂。所以当你观察到并发现它们时，把它发到推特上，加上Unseen City的标签，我们会关注的。如果你像我一样喜欢在床上读书，睡在伴侣旁边，并且喜欢说：嘿，你知道蜗牛是怎么回事吗？它们有两个触角，这样它们就能找到钙。朋友们，这本书非常适合你。每隔五分钟，你就会说出类似的话。Nathaniel，非常感谢你能来这里。99% Invisible的成员有Sam Greenspan、Delaney Hall、Kurt Colesde、Katie Mingle、Avery Truffleman、Sharif Yousef，还有我Roman Mars。感谢旧金山加州科学院的Nightlife活动，它位于金门
Park. You can explore music, creatures, and cocktails with other curious minded adults every Thursday night at the museum. It is a cool day you should definitely go. We are a project of 91.7 KLW St. Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, you can follow us all on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design
公园。每周四晚上，你都可以在博物馆与其他好奇的成年人一起探索音乐、生物和鸡尾酒。这是一个很酷的地方，你一定要去看看。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW电台的一个项目，在加州美丽的奥克兰市中心的建筑与室内设计公司ArcSign的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞我们的节目，也可以在推特和Instagram上关注我们，但探索塑造我们世界设计的99% Invisible活动的最好方式
of our world is to become friends with our website, it's 99pi.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是访问我们的网站99pi.org。Radio Tapio来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。